the last lecture will be given by
rahulango and we will hear about another
exciting results
and it's in about the arithmetic
assuming some cryptographic assumptions
all right so thank you very much for the
introduction and coming to my talk uh I
will
do my very best not to keep you guys
away from lunch uh very soon so this is
Joint work with jock Julie who you heard
about in the last talk a fantastic
undergrad at xingwa and my advisor Ryan
Williams and so so for for the people I
did talk about this earlier in the
semester in uh in the meta complexity
seminar that that talk I had crossed out
the Bandit arithmetic part but for this
talk I've highlighted the bounded
arithmetic talk so
okay so this talk is going to be about
the unprovability of the Dual wig
picture null principle uh in certain
theories so so what is the Dual League
pigeonhole principle something we've
heard about already
um it just says if you put n pigeons
into two two n pigeonhole then there
must be a lonely pigeonhole no a
pigeonhole without a pigeon and and the
factor two here is isn't so important
you want some some Gap but uh uh the
factor well let's just say let's just
deal with the case with this factor of
two
and so like uh this
simple result is uh very nice for us
complexity theorists because it implies
various things so like for example the
fact that there is a Boolean function on
end inputs with high circuit complexity
uh follows for example from this dual
Beats
and so
civilization that we're going to deal
with uh in this talk and I'll actually
this I'll be a little bit unconformal
here I'll be more formal later is some
sort of for all exists for all
statements we're saying that uh let's
say for all circuits that map n Bits to
n plus one bits so this is uh
there are two to the N inputs here there
are two to the uh n plus one inputs here
so this is this Factor two that we saw
before there exists some
uh string of length n plus one that is
not in the range of the circuit so for
all x c of X is not equal to Y so this
is for all exists for all statement uh
might not be clear yet why this is
important but this will come up again
later okay so we have some so we have
some nice combinatorial principle we can
ask
how hard is it to prove in
various theories and so thankfully we've
heard a lot about bounded arithmetic
today and so uh you know we've heard
about pb1 which for my talk I mean
thankfully we've already seen like a a
nice definition of it but for my talk uh
all you need to know is that this is
some proof system corresponding to
polynomial time reasoning you also need
to know witnessing theorem that I'll
tell you about later but for now just
nice some nice uh
some nice crew system corresponding to
polynomial time reasoning in fact just
to give you some intuition all I'm going
to say about pv1 uh I just want to give
this example on the one hand pv1 is kind
of weak in that it can't prove that any
one-way permutation is subjective uh but
on the other hand it's really strong in
that it can prove the PCP theorem so it
can't prove like these very basic facts
about groups and uh on the other hand it
can prove the PCP theorem so this is in
some sense it's very powerful in other
sentences
oh uh no no but it can't prove any
one-way permutation it's a the condition
is in the statements yeah yeah it was
very sneaky
um okay so we have a PV one and so now
let me tell you what uh what our main
result is
so our main result is pv1 under some
assumptions
cannot prove
the Dual weak original principle for PV
functions which uh if you know about
boundary arithmetic this is a precise
formalization I'm not going to go go
through it in detail
so but pv1 cannot prove to do weak
prison hole principles under the
following assumptions
so the first assumption is that NP is
not in co-am infinitely often so under
de-randomization assumption this is
basically just NP not equal to Coen P
infinitely often
so that's a nice complexity theoretic
assumption
assumption might be less familiar uh to
the audience but we'll also hear about
it later in the day a sub-exponentially
secure whatever that means
indistinguishability obfuscaters
whatever that means I'll tell you about
them later in the talk so assuming that
these two things exist you can prove
that you won uh does not prove
and as a corollary are pretty much
directly you get that APC one whatever
that is Igor to find it in his last talk
if you're uh is a strict extension of
pv1 and uh why this might be a little
bit uh why this is interesting is like
so as Igor mentioned in this talk this
this class kind of informally
corresponds to probabilistic polynomial
time reasoning this class kind of
informally corresponds to
um polynomial time reasoning so you
might think uh you know P equals VPP so
then maybe these two things are the same
but in fact uh they're they're uh under
these assumptions
they're uh they're they're different
and I should say uh oh or actually or
okay maybe I'll say this and then take
questions so there there has been some
prior work on this so that you can get
an oracle separation of APC one versus
pv1 this was shown by uh yeah herbic and
uh you can also get that the two-week
original principle is not proved in pv1
under the assumption that P is in size n
to the K but maybe that's a unlikely
assumption I guess depending on what you
believe
okay any questions about this
assume both of these conditions yeah
assembled with these conditions yeah
sorry so this unprovability is based on
but um
and then you say that your shopback
already proved that
um APC one is uh it's not conservative
of a pv1
not right like that
yeah yeah there's been an oracle
relative to which you can't hear this
and this was like saying maybe under
reasonable assumptions that in our our
world uh
right previous results
previous results you're saying that
other circuit upper bounds oh I'll prove
them yeah this is so this is an unlikely
unlike well I guess it depends yes but
maybe uh this is an unlikely uh
assumption right right good good
Okay cool so let me tell you a little
bit about how this is proved so the
proof overview actually breaks down into
two very nice steps
so the first step is to say for
contradiction suppose pv1 did prove the
Dual leak digital principle
okay what do we get out of this and so
there's a very nice Hammer we can use so
by the kpt witnessing theorem which I'll
tell you about uh in a bit but uh it's
just a nice Hammer tells you that
there's some sort of algorithm for a
related problem which I'll also tell you
about later called circuit range
avoidance so you transition from a
provability uh in pv1 to an algorithm
for some related problem
okay and I'll tell you about that later
and then the next step is to show that
actually this algorithm
uh doesn't exist and this is the part
that uses indistinguishability
applications so this part is uh oh sorry
not not assuming you have
indistinguishable obfuscation this gives
you a non-deterministic algorithm for
verifying unsatisfiability uh or in
particular and NP is in co-am infinitely
awesome
so
okay so what I'm going to do in the rest
of the first part of the talk is I'm
going to tell you how to do this so this
is a relatively standard thing but I
just want to go through it and then in
the second part of the talk I'll tell
you about this
so uh I mentioned this problem circuit
range avoidance so what exactly is this
problem
so I I don't have time in my talk to
talk about all all the literature on
circuit range avoidance it's a very nice
problem with lots of interesting results
but let me tell you a little bit about
what's known about in what's going to be
relevant for our talk so it's this
problem that was defined by kleinberg
Courtney metropolsky and papa dimitrio
they are interested in total function
problems in the polynomial hierarchy and
as you can maybe tell from this input
output description it's very closely
related to The Dual weak pigeonhole
principle you're given some circuit that
Maps end it's to M bits where m is
greater than n and your goal is to
Output
some something that's not in the range
of the circuit
and there are many such strings just by
accounting argument and
um
so as a result there's a very simple
randomized algorithm in fact a
randomized algorithm is so simple it
doesn't even look at its input it just
outputs a random
okay and so you have a randomized
algorithm and an extremely natural
question to ask is you know does there
existed deterministic uh algorithm for
this problem so what do you guys think
who thinks that there should be a
deterministic algorithm
who thinks I should not be a
yeah so I've sort of given you the
punchline punchline away already but uh
yeah under the same assumptions that I
talked about earlier there is not a
deterministic algorithm and what makes
this kind of interesting is that like uh
it was the you know unknown prior to
this whether there's any plausible
assumptions under which you can show
that uh avoid does not have a
deterministic algorithm it wasn't even
clear what what the ground truth was
what was known was that if you did have
deterministic algorithm you had all
sorts of amazing explicit Construction
consequences you get explicit truth
tables with high circuit complexity you
get good explicit Ramsay graphs true
Source extractors rigid matrices uh and
so on and these were consequences that
were uh really nice and things we didn't
know how to prove but they were all
things that we believed so it wasn't
like evidence that a deterministic
algorithm shouldn't exist it was just
nice consequences of it
okay so that's what I wanted to say
about range avoidance now I'm going to
come back to how if you proved in pv1
that the do we improve the dual-week
picture General principle in pv1 how
that implies some sort of algorithm for
range avoidance is there any questions
about range avoidance before I move on
okay great
so there's this Hammer I mentioned which
is kpt witnessing which is proved by cry
check putlock and
91 and it basically says I'm going to
State it informally and then just tell
you what the consequences for uh our
problem is
if pv1 proved some sort of for all
exists for all statement then there is
some sort of algorithm witnessing this
and I'll be more specific about what I
mean by algorithm witnessing it in a
second
but in our setting you have the two-week
pigeonhole principle which was this for
all exists for all statement
and so as a result uh kind of directly a
direct consequence of kpt is that
whenever if pv1 proved the Dual League
pigeonhole principle
there is and this is where the algorithm
was put in quotes a constant round
polynomial time deterministic
student-teacher algorithm for weight I'm
going to tell you what that is on the
next slide I'll walk you through it
um but it's some sort of algorithmic way
to solve a blade so what exactly is the
algorithm
so the algorithm looks like this
so uh on the one hand you have a very
wise
uh helpful teacher
uh
like Rahul and on the other hand you
have a misguided but well-meaning kind
of dinky student on the other hand like
Rahul and uh
their goal is the goal is the student
wants to solve a void on some circuits
and so what does the student do the
student you know
ah looks at looks at looks at the circus
like uh maybe Isn't So diligent and uh
oh sorry so what is a student a student
as we all know is K deterministic
polynomial time algorithms
and so just A1 up to AK
and so the student will look at the
circuit and say hey I think that uh y1
is not in the range of the circuit
and then the very wise teacher will look
and and be like uh well okay that was a
good try but uh actually it is in the
range of the circuit the hands back some
X1 I've chosen right
the student goes back oh okay okay very
good very good uh oh yes I know uh
oh I too I think it's I think Y2 is not
in the range of the circuit yeah student
teacher's like okay you're getting a
little bit better with give Zach an
example and uh importantly the student
is allowed to see the characters
and so basically a k round student
teacher game is some a game like this
where the student will eventually find a
counter example in at most K routes and
and the kpt witnessing theorem will show
uh that you had an algorithm that
succeeds in a constant number of rounds
is the definition of this clear
oh and I want to mention that it's
really important that these out for our
purpose that these algorithms are
deterministic because as I mentioned
earlier if you allowed Randomness
there's this very simple algorithm for
this teacher the student where you just
uniformly random
okay awesome
so returning to our proof overview we've
done the first step they said if pv1
proves the two-week picture hold
principle then by kpt witnessing there's
a student teacher algorithm for a
certain range applicants oh yes the
number of K depends on the length of the
proof well that's a good question
actually I don't know I mean it's so
it's going to be a constant I don't know
what the dependence on K is
reproductions
uh so it's some constant it'll depend on
the group and so this is the first part
and now the second part that I want to
tell you about is that uh if you assume
the existence of sufficiently good and
distinguishability obfuscation which I
still haven't told you with this
yeah
okay so let me tell you a bit about
indistinguishable so the the study of
cryptographic obfuscation at least the
modern study that dates back to this
figure by Barack at all in 2001
and
the goal I mean
I mean your hand at a circuit C
and somehow you want to scramble this
circuit
into some uh authors get it so I can see
that computes the same function
but
ideally and I'm going to be a bit
unformally in a second you know like uh
this circuit doesn't really tell you
anything and so one way you can
formalize it that anything you can
compute using the obfuscation you could
compute uh with black box access
to the function computed by this
so I this is I I'm gonna be a bit uh
hand wavy here but this is kind of
saying all you can do with the circuit
instrument like you won't be able to
learn any other information based on
except when you just you write it on the
input you saw what the output is sorry
and this would be a really great really
strong notion except that it doesn't
exist
so there is a there's a nice proof it's
almost halting yes where you take an
object station you run it on itself you
do something and then you get a
contradiction so this definition is too
strong
and so what did the cryptographers do I
mean they're very uh they're uh
they're they're Brave you know you know
this didn't deter them if it's
impossible let's do it and uh they came
up with a different definition which is
indistinguishability application
so this is the definition we're going to
be talking about
and it says
what is an indistinguishable I mean some
sort of randomized algorithm it takes us
input a circuit it also takes this input
a security parameter but let's not worry
about that for now I'm going to admit
writing it
and it has the following two properties
the first property as you'd expect is
that for all circuit C
the obfuscator will output a circuit
competing the same function
well there's actually one thing I want
to stress about this uh if you're making
this definition
you might not
have to aim for perfect functionality I
mean maybe it was extremely small
probability you'll output a circuit
which computes a different function
it turns out this isn't the the this is
not uh it turns out you can actually
hope for the stronger games perfect
functionality and we're going to use it
this is going to be important
so perfect functionality remember that
that'll come back later
and so the security guarantee
and this is the mean of the definition
is something that's much weaker that
forms on the previous slide it says
whenever you had two circuits
of approximately the same size Computing
the same exact same function
then when you obfuscate the two circuits
so you have the ioc and the ioc prime
they're approximately the same size they
compute the same function you can't tell
which circuit you start with so like if
after you've obfuscated this no
adversary adversary Circuit of size
is able to tell the difference between
whether you obfuscate in the first
circuit or the second circuit except
with extremely small purposes
so let me give you to give you some
intuition for this um
let me say like here's an example of a
trivial uh indistinguishability
atmosphere
it's not a it's not an efficient one but
it's trivial you just take your circuit
and find the lexicographically first uh
circuit that computes the same function
so this thing will that opportunity
office skater takes a lot of time but it
will guarantee this so that we have two
circuits that can keep the same function
it's going to get the same output
but you know that's under unlikely
assumption one of the crown jewels I
mean you heard about the jewel theorem
in uh and proof complexity one of the
crown jewels of cryptography in the past
few years is that actually you can
construct sub-exponentially secure in
the similarious developmentation under
well-founded assumption so this is this
paper of Jane went into high if you're
curious these assumptions are uh uh
sub-exponentially secure learning parody
and always a sub-exponentially secure
some bilinear map is also some
exponentially secure and then uh there
are nc0 prgs with arbitrary arbitrary
polynomial Edge anyway okay the the very
nice assumptions and under which those
under those assumptions you actually get
instead of exponentially secure I'm
sorry you have a question
okay how is episode 45 how is Epsilon
Quantified okay so there will be exist
some Epsilon this is just some fixed
constant maybe think of it at one over
uh 100 or something like that
foreign
okay good
so now what do we need to prove
what we're going to show or actually not
what we're going to show but what we
show in the paper is is some externally
secure i o exists and there was a
student teacher algorithm for a void as
I described on the previous slide then
NP is going to be in Coe and infinitely
often
uh in this talk I'm not going to show
that I'm going to tell you a little bit
about this a simpler proof which is
let's we'll still assume somebody
actually secure i o but instead of
assuming there was a constant number of
rounds let's just assume there was one
round which is just that avoid has uh
deterministic algorithm so let's let's
let's simplify things there's not a
constant number of rounds there's one
round which just means you can solve a
void indeterministic quality
and actually then you can get a stronger
consequence which is NP is equal to
column P by the way this is a void FP
but you've been talking about avoiding a
circuit computable function
right yeah so the translation is that
really you have like this e-value
problem you take like this eval uh
yeah
and then so does that answer your
question right now
so the question is whether it makes a
difference oh yeah
because you should follow the real-time
algorithm that checks if a formula is
satisfiable
oh sorry it's unsatisfied
okay and so how much time do I have I
have five minutes I guess five minutes
yes
so what does the reduction look like
so we're given some formula fee on N
inputs what's our non-deterministic
algorithm
the algorithm is going to say output
unsatisfiable
if there exists it's going to
existentially guess a y of length n plus
one
and some random some R so these are just
two strings it's just going to guess two
strings we'll worry about what they are
are and what their meaning is later it's
going to guess two strings and it's
going to check the following condition
so what is this condition
so I'm going to use the notation I'm
going to say I'm going to let avoid
stand for its deterministic algorithm
I'll let i o stand for its algorithm so
what I'm going to say is you have to uh
output onset if you can guess a y and an
R such that when you run the avoid
algorithm
on the obfuscation
of some circuit I actually haven't told
you what the circuit is yet we'll come
back to it it's some circuit that you
can construct given fee and Y come back
to it later
with Randomness R you'd get back y
okay this is the reduction uh let me
recap it again you'll just you're just
going to run the void algorithm on
obfuscation of some circuit with
Randomness R and you're going to guess
the Y to put here and you're going to
guess the r puts here we're gonna see if
you need a back line
now I haven't told you what this circuit
is but hopefully you agree with me that
as long as that circuit is efficiently
constructable this is a
non-deterministic polynomial timeout
does that make sense
yes okay so let me tell you what the
circuit is oh and I should mention also
there's the security parameter which
I've been hiding but it's some
polynomial and feel let's not worry
about it
uh so what is this circuit this circuit
and if you're familiar with the
cryptographic literature it's basically
this construction of witness encryption
from i o
um
the second and fee constructed from fee
and Y is Computing the following
function given X
it'll output the all zeros
if a fee is not satisfied at X
on the other hand if fee is satisfied at
X it's going to Output y
so it's something that uh
if C would happen to be unsatisfiable
this is just the all zeros function
on the other hand if fee is satisfiable
then Y is going to be hitting hidden
somewhere there
and just some remarks so this is exactly
a circuit that we can use range
avoidance on because it's mapping n Bits
to n plus one bits
and also something that's kind of
interesting about this circuit it
actually has range of exactly two yeah I
mean this thing has a very small range
it turns out it's already hard to solve
range avoidance on this
and so okay I guess I have three minutes
so
it's great let me see if there's any
questions in this slide first I can tell
you a bit about soundness the proof of
soundness isn't too hard to see
but if there's any questions
avoid you're assuming it's deterministic
and that's why this is empty
but if if you take the trivial
randomized algorithm then it's a May
right so what will happen is um
you you so you're saying why not what
happens when we plug the randomized
algorithm into here that's what you're
asking what happens is that what you're
asking are you asking me yeah okay and
what will happen is then this this
argument won't work it like uh if this
is not going to be a witness of
unsatisfiability in fact for every fee
you're just going to exist in R and A Y
such that this is true also the
randomized algorithm you can't control
that line
foreign
basically already said this if the
reduction says fee is unsatisfiable
and what does that mean it means that
there existed a y and an R such that
this condition held
okay
by the correctness of the avoid
algorithm here's crucially where the
fact that you're using it's
deterministic and doesn't make errors
is that Y is not in the range of I of
this obfuscated circuit if a void was a
randomized algorithm you don't
necessarily know this is true
and now by the perfect functionality of
i o here's where you're using that it's
PR it has perfect functionality you know
that Y is not in the range of C Phi
and then by the definition of cvy this
means that Phi is unsatisfied
okay did that make sense
okay
so the so the harder direction is
completeness which I won't tell you
about now but if you're interested you
can come talk to me the proof isn't too
long
uh but thank you very much for listening
and if you have any questions
foreign
uh yeah the reason why you get am
actually is it it you don't get it in
this one round case but when you go to
con a student teacher algorithm we're
constantly many rounds it turns out you
need to do some approximate counting
it's uh it probably won't be clear from
this but you uh from this sketch but
when you go to constantly many rounds
you care it turns out you need to do
some approximate accounting
okay
randomization assumption it's an FP uh
um
oh right yeah so you've only sure I had
this nice question okay so one of uh one
of the reasons why you might be
interested in studying the complexity of
a boy why would you be interested in
this thing actually without these
determinants of Technology it's because
like this gives a complexity theoretic
way of actually constructing all of
these objects we think should have
explicit instructions it's like a
central thing such as a given
deterministic remember this we construct
all the things I mean if you have an NP
Oracle you still get it as you should
but like if you wanted to just get a
some condition under which you can
deterministically construct
Ramsay graphs two Source extractors
whatever
is there some other problem or some
other assumption under which you can you
can get that
do that make sense and so you can get a
list construction under classic
de-randomization of assumptions you can
construct a list of objects such that
one of them is going to be a good two
Source extractor but what if you want to
know exactly you know you wanted one
object you said this is two source to
check and in some sense you know we
already have it you know you take the
digits of pi that'll be your two Source
extractor or whatever uh I mean yeah
it'll work but can we give a complexity
theoretic
yeah great question so it turns out
um this approach under reasonable
cryptographic or plausible cryptographic
assumptions will rule out even ac0 or
even nc04 NC uh nc0 where every output
that depends on those four input that's
I mean okay it depends what
cryptographic assumptions you believe
uh nc03 is an open question there's been
some more recently that again came out
recently that gets it in a large stretch
regime but nnc02 we know how that exists
in column a good time
algorithm yeah yeah
right but can you yeah yeah so can can
you come up with a nice or something I
mean if you generate strings with large
complexity right you know you'll have
this but you know can you get something
nice yeah
depending on about the statement that
Awards is in like average speed on the
uh
uh so remind me average key means you
can make error in two directions and uh
I'll understand yeah let's say you can
you can okay yeah but yeah I would say
yes and I would say just take the
digital Supply
that's true you run the Oracle right
that's when you run the oracle
oh this is true
actually in our paper we have like for
complexity like uh
hey
Jesus